thank you okay yeah we'll introduce
myself shortly then I will talk about
where we do come from regarding offline
capabilities of browsers after that I
want to point out what's different now
with service workers and after that we
dive in and I'll show you how to
implement them and yeah after that a
little outlook on what's next so okay
who's talking here yeah my name is
similar ill and I'm a JavaScript
developer here in Hamburg at gym do we
are offering like a website builder for
the common people i'm also on twitter
and get up you can click the link if you
are interested in that i will post the
slides after the talk so okay where do
we come from you already have heard of
it I think it's the app cache manifest I
call it the unloved child well i did i
do that i mean it has a declarative API
that's easy to use on the first glance
you just set up a file like manifest app
cache and put in the path of the files
you want to be cached and after their to
register this fire and by putting this
manifest a tribute to the HTML element
and then you're good to go that's it the
browser parses this file and puts all
the stuff in the app cache sounds great
actually but I have this quote by Jake
Archibald he wrote in an article and he
said the application cares cashback it's
like an onion it has many many layers
and SPS rulem you'll be reduced to tears
which sounds harsh actually yeah why is
that well first of all you actually have
no control over what content is loaded
with the application cache so you can't
be sure or like in other way the
application cache will always serve
cash content even if there's a fresh
version and when the flash version of
the file is loaded from the network then
there's an update ready event and the
user has to reload the page to get the
new version you could do it yourself
with navigator on a location reload but
the problem is the user may already have
interacted with the page and then you
can't just reload it and the user loses
all the stuff he has done till this
moment so yet a little bit complicated
to get new stuff served the other thing
is it is not enough to to change files
and provide them but you have to change
the manifest itself to signal to the
application cat hey there are some
changes please have a look yeah it's not
that nice and the other funny thing is
the application cache interferes with
the normal browser caching so one might
think it is an replacement for the bra
for the browser cache but this is not
the case so even if you manage to tell
the application cache on to load a new
version the browser still might say well
the cache headers say it's valid for
five years I serve the old version so to
prevent this you have to disable the
normal caching for all files that you
want to have on the application cache
the sucks and you don't let at you
content during runtime so we have a
static file the manifest file and that's
it during runtime of your web app
there's no way to edit this fire so if
you want to cache dynamic content
request it during runtime you have to do
some hacking with local host or browser
databases and finally it doesn't require
HTTPS just sounds nice but it leads to
sound security flaws which I don't want
to point out in detail about that you
can google it up
and yeah all these points let mozilla to
even say okay that's enough we remove
the support for app cache well soon you
won't be able to use app cache in
Firefox anymore and maybe other browser
we're not will follow I don't know at
the moment but it is possible so yeah
what is actually different service
workers then service worker it's a new
approach to caching and first of all
they have no declarative API by the
programmatic IPI so you write JavaScript
and tell the browser which files to cash
and when to low load or serve which
contents and this javascript is executed
in a serviceworker threat during the run
time and as a service workers running it
acts like a proxy between your web
application and the network so we have
full control over which requests go go
out and so you can remove files and add
files to the cash during the run time so
you are not limited to static assets
that you define before deploying your
web app but you can do this in the rant
at runtime yeah and finally as the
service work as a proxy you have full
control what to serve there are several
strategies to what serve when if to hit
the cash out forward the request to the
network I will point out that later okay
so that the theoretical background let's
have a look at how to use them there are
some prerequisites and first you need a
secure connection this is learning from
the app cache luckily you don't need it
on the localhost so you don't have to go
through the hassle to install a
certificate when you just want to fill
around on your machine another thing is
the support of the browsers at the
moment only five
and opera and chrome support service
workers log on mobile and desktop
browsers but actually there shouldn't be
a problem so service workers are
regarded as a progressive enhancement
and your web app should we work fine
without them and get even better when
the users browser support service
workers and finally you should have a
basic understanding of promises so the
API around service workers makes heavily
user of them and if you aren't familiar
with promises the code might look a
little awkward okay first of all if you
want to use service workers you have to
register them and yeah as I said it's a
progressive enhancement so we first look
at the the Navigator object if there's
this property service worker and if this
exists the browser should support them
and we call the register method and
register our service worker jas file
that's one thing to have in mind here
the location of this file defines the
scope so if you are used to put all your
javascript in a J a subfolder you might
be tempted to do to do the same with the
service work of fire but then your users
won't have any caching because they
won't go in in the part of your web app
where j/s isn't part of your web app
then for the user so normally I think
you want to do I put this in the root of
your web app
there's also another way in the making
and this isn't supported at the moment
but soon crown was supported in Firefox
signaled that they like this approach as
well and this is a declarative way to
register the service worker with the
link element I just put it here for
completeness then when your service
workers finally registered you can yet
start managing your caches and in the
file first of all you need aversion to
to control which files are cached and
which old files to delete so every time
you edit this version you have the
opportunity to clean up your cash I
choose this number but you can choose
whatever string you want like animal
names or your favorite manga characters
they only have to change when you deploy
a new state yeah after that I define an
area with static assets like the
index.html and some CSS some JavaScript
a nice image to make it more beautiful
and in the life cycle of the
serviceworker there's this installation
process and when this happens the car
back on the lifecycle event is called
and the event object that is passed into
it has this wait until method which
expects the promise so the installation
stops at this moment and we have the
opportunity to put our files into the
cache then the process goes on so we
open the cash and put our static files
into it by the way this caches object
it's not only available in the service
worker but also in your main web
application on the windows object so you
could actually put contents into the
cash from there if this does make sense
in the situation
so yeah we have put our contents into
the cash and the life cycle goes on next
it will be activated and there again we
have a call an event to to attach a call
vector and here we have again our event
wait until method and when the service
worker is activated we can clean the
caches by getting all the keys from it
and compared to our current version and
if the cash doesn't match our current
regime be just deleted stuff and so
everything is tidy and we only have the
latest content in our cash here then
finally after the activation was
successful the service workers start
intercepting event requests and every
time a request is made in our web app
this car baganda fetch event is called
and there we have a respond with method
on our event object which expects a
expected promise which then gets the
contents that are served to the web app
and as I only have static assets in my
cash at the moment I immediately hit the
cash I don't have to go to the network
because I know what is needed actually
there are no requests planned so I look
up with the match method on the cash and
if there's a response I return this and
if there is no fire or no resource found
then the response is undefined and then
I forward to request and to the network
with the fatty function and yeah that's
the basic usage of the service worker
actually what we've seen so far is like
a usage and there is quite similar to
the app cache we have static files I'm
defined before before deployment of our
web app but it all happens with less
pain and more control and hopefully more
security will but what is more
interesting with service work
the caching of dynamic content so let's
go on and look how to do this there are
basically two strategies when it comes
to us dynamic contents requested during
the run time and the first one is
network first so you immediately forward
the request to the network and if it
fails you look up in the cache if you
have an old version and if it succeeds
you update the cache and you serve the
response to the web app yeah this code
is a bit a little bit just a little bit
more code about this approach first of
all we have another version for the
dynamic contents so it doesn't interfere
with our static assets and we
immediately forward the request to the
network and inside the decor back and
the Dan then method and we open our cash
with our current version and update the
cache that matches the requested
resource and we have this funny thing
here we have to clone the response so
responses response objects when they are
used once they're used up and gun so you
can't use the poor response for the cash
and for returning it to the web app we
have to clone it so the cash gets a
clone and the original one gets served
to the web app and finally if this fails
we just look up in the cache if we have
an old version to serve what we see here
is that we don't have to care about the
online status of the user there's this
online property on the navigator object
which tells us if the users online or
not but it isn't reliable so if users
are on shitty mobile connections which
leads to time outs or if they are on an
airport and don't want to pay for
the Wi-Fi this property you will tell us
we are the users online but actually
they aren't and with the service worker
of this approach to hit the network and
then look up in the cash we don't have
to care about that just do our stuff and
finally something will come to the user
yeah when to use this approach this is
good for for data that is updated very
frequently like soccer data at the
weekend so if you have a web app
displaying soccer results you might not
want to show the user the results from
the last weekend but the act the current
want to hit the network and if that
fails yeah you have to go with all data
and weather forecasts and stock market
data are typical examples for this kind
of contents here the other approach
would be to go cash first so just look
up in the cash and serve content really
fast but also do a request to look if
there's a new version of this resource
the code is a little bit different I
have this unavailable function i hope
you can read this from behind actually
this is okay no one said anything that's
good yeah this is unavailable function
which return to response with status are
five or three this is our last resort
but hopefully we'll get contents before
so we immediately start hitting the cash
and look for a resource that matches our
request and at the end you can see we
return this but we also do our request
and again update the cache mr. the
response of the request succeeds and if
the result from the cache is undefined
we will return our fetch promise and if
this fails as well then yeah we have to
take our unavailable function that
returns to five or three so we can
either return all the content fast
or a newer content from the network or
we fail gracefully with a 5 or 3 yeah
this is a good strategy for for contents
that aren't saw updated so frequently
like rock pools and news articles there
you can surf fast which is always good
yeah I kind of lied to you when I said
there are basically two strategies and
there are more you might have contents
where you don't want to serve old stuff
and only hit the network and don't
deserve anything at all if the users not
online you may also have contents where
you only have to hit the cash remember
the first example where I defined the
static assets I can be pretty sure that
they are installed every time the web
app is loaded and the service workers
installed so actually you don't have to
talk about anything and to the network I
just can hit the cash and serve really
fast and boost performance of my web app
and asses fastest approach on some
devices maybe take some time to to read
from disk if the device is old and test
a slow disk i/o operation and if you
request a very small aesthetic asset it
might be faster to get it from the
network so you can start a race and make
the request to the network and ask the
cash and whoever's fastest allowed to
self eventually so this was it yeah
what's next there are some service
worker related specifications for
example they push API which enables you
to annoy your users with push
notifications and what's nice about
service workers is that they they are
running in a threat in the background so
even if the web app is not active they
can receive push notifications and you
can handle them also and it does the
interesting thing is the back
think so the browser can store made
requests like post requests that the
user writes a message or something
similar and if the user then is offline
it's stored in the background and then
zoomed when the user goes online yeah
and finally give a fencing um it's a
good way to react to the the kaiserin
when the user enters or leaves a
specific region you could do this with
geolocation but here again we have this
nice thing that the background the
service worker is running in a
background so the web app doesn't have
to be active and you can react to this
nonetheless yeah what's also next is I
propose you learn more about service
workers and I have a list of resources
which I can recommend like a very good
introduction to the topic on html5 rocks
calm and if you are more into this topic
this offline cookbook by Jake Archibald
is covering some summer strategies to
serve content and they are suspect was
the UL service work ers this is a
collection of some very interesting
recipes it goes really deep into the
topic and also nice is instant loading
with service workers it's a video from a
talk at Google i/o and it also covers
tooling around service workers like
having a guard task building a service
worker including all the aesthetic
assets and fresh version strings and he
talks about the polymer component that
handles service workers declaratively I
recommend this even if you don't want to
use this component but it's interesting
to see how they solve problems coming up
yeah and if you want to see what the
browser supporters have a look at this
website that's interesting to see how
the things develop yeah and finally if
you have your own web app boosted with
service workers you might need a service
with HTTPS I can recommend search dot as
age I put my demos up there you get a
subdomain and can force https or you
want to use cloud sec for your get up
pages with a custom domain or finally
let's encrypt thought the latest
solution for bringing https to the
masses yeah that's finally it thanks for
listening if you have questions then
please ask me